chris is with us in Orlando Florida hi
Chris how are you good
thanks for taking my call hey I heard
you talking to the other caller about a
rental car and not using a credit card
that you use a debit part I haven't had
a credit card in 25 years why don't you
use a credit card as a debit card for
fraud protection I use the debit card
has the exact same fraud protection that
a credit card has well my the debit
cards that happens which they will give
it back but my experience I've been and
I and we've helped some friends out of
some situations because they had like
their debit card was so impressed they
used it and the number was stolen and
they took out four or five hundred
dollars whatever in fraud the bank's say
yeah we'll took the money back in but it
could take up to ten days to put the
money back yeah yeah and and they were
just freaking out on all right my
electric to build a mortgage now is
going to bounce that money's not there
my wife and I use our credit card a
credit card like a debit card and we've
had we just recently not what credit
card that we try to use that card and
there was fraud on it no it's white
clean we don't have to worry about that
what we do the same thing happen with my
debit card three weeks ago
that's why complain and I don't have to
worry about it right but you have to
have that money also y'all know I'm not
broke I have more than five hundred
dollars to my name which is also we
recommend which is also how we recommend
people live credit cards are a really
dumb idea for really broke people and
debit cards are you know they can leave
a broke person in trouble too so you
need to get to more of a cash basis when
you're that broke it's yearning about
500 bucks to your name well when you're
working at sometimes no stop a second
okay I've been doing this 30 years
you're not going to talk me into using a
credit card I'm the guy that's cut up
more credit cards and cause more people
to stop using credit cards than anyone
in the
three the United States I so you're
really not going to talk me out all our
mothers no I'm trying to understand okay
then then listen and I'll tell then
listen and I tell you okay
the fraud protection is exactly the same
when I have never met a millionaire and
I've met thousands of millionaires and
my years of doing financial coaching
never met a single one that said Dave I
made all my money with my airline miles
I made all my money with my stupid bonus
points so I'm not buying that one when
you use a credit card all of the studies
and there's tons of behavioral studies
out there that show this you spend 12 to
18 percent more than when you spend cash
and you do spend more than you do with a
debit card because there's a part of
your brain that understands you're
actually spending real money when you're
spending with a debit card people spend
more money they get in more trouble and
I talk to people that are thousands and
tens of thousands of dollars in debt
with credit cards every single day
they're a snake the stupid companies
figure out every possible way to screw
you on the planet so why would you play
with snakes because you're not smart
that's the only reason you would play
with snakes so don't play with snakes
it's that simple dude you spend more it
doesn't make you rich it makes you broke
it's the mantra of the middle-class
don't do it this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you